[Música]
Estados Unidos se comprometió a
Modificar el acuerdo del Tercer país
seguro y Canadá aceptó recibir a 15.000
migrantes del continente el próximo año
a esos pactos llegaron los líderes de
ambas naciones en su encuentro en el que
Washington no descartó enviar una misión
militar Haití
inició en República Dominicana la
versión número 28 de la Cumbre
iberoamericana un encuentro que gira en
torno al medio ambiente la seguridad
alimentaria y la integración entre
América andorra España y Portugal
ampliamos los detalles con nuestra
enviada especial
el viernes miles de argentinos marcharon
en Buenos Aires para recordar a las
víctimas de la dictadura militar que
llegó al poder hace 47 años los
manifestantes portaron pancartas con
fotos de los desaparecidos y exigieron
Justicia
Bienvenidos a este informativo con las
noticias más relevantes del continente
americano soy Valentina Torres Sánchez y
es un gusto acompañarlos iniciamos en
Canadá donde se llevó a cabo el
encuentro oficial entre el Primer
Ministro Justin trudea y el presidente
Joe biden la reunión giró en torno a
temas como la migración la situación de
Haití y la unidad como bandera para
enfrentar a regímenes autoritarios
es la primera visita oficial del
presidente de Estados Unidos Joe biden
al país vecino y Aliado Canadá donde el
Primer Ministro Justin trudó lo recibió
con los brazos abiertos es un verdadero
placer dar la bienvenida al presidente
biden autagua de vuelta a otawa me
alegro mucho de verte yo el principal
objetivo de la visita reforzar su
cooperación económica y social durante
la reunión anunciaron un acuerdo sobre
la migración ilegal en la frontera
compartida un tema sensible para ambos
bandos según este Canadá podrá devolver
a los migrantes en caliente sin
permitirles la entrada país a cambio de
conceder 15.000 solicitudes de asilo un
movimiento criticado por las
organizaciones humanitarias Estados
Unidos y Canadá trabajarán juntos para
desalentar los cruces ilegales en las
fronteras y aplicar el acuerdo del
Tercer país plenamente y totalmente
actualizado también discutieron otros
temas como un plan conjunto de defensa
para poder plantar cara a otras
potencias como Rusia o china
lo que hace que este sea un momento tan
trascendental es que nuestro mundo
nuestro modo de vida se enfrenta a
múltiples amenazas al mismo tiempo
e hicieron hincapié en su apoyo a
Ucrania en la región aseguraron que
siguen preocupados por la situación de
seguridad en Haití Canadá suele ser la
primera visita al extranjero del
presidente estadounidense Y aunque con
biden no fue así han querido subrayar
que la unidad norteamericana sigue
intacta
una aparente caso de intimidación se
vivió en la oficina del fiscal que
podría presentar cargos contra el
expresidente Donald Trump por supuesto
sobornos pagados a la actriz
pornográfica Story Daniels de otra parte
el ex mandatario advirtió que de ser
procesado por este delito habría muerte
y destrucción
no hay respiro cuando se trata de Donald
Trump este viernes el departamento de
policía de Nueva York acudió a la
oficina del fiscal de distrito de
Manhattan Alvin bracket para retirar
sobres con polvo blanco de naturaleza
desconocida estos sobres fueron enviados
junto a una nota de amenaza al fiscal
que estudia presentar cargos por
supuesto sobornos de Trump a la actriz
de cine para adultos
storms al mismo tiempo Trump ha hecho
una incendiaria publicación en su red
social advirtiendo que habrá muerte y
destrucción si se presenta una acusación
en su contra habrá consecuencias
catastróficas según el expresidente que
tilda de psicópata degenerado a quien se
atreva a imputarlo un tono que vuelve a
causar preocupación
La retórica del expresidente que fue
sometido dos veces a juicio político es
temeraria cuestionable e irresponsable
es Y si sigue así va a ser que maten a
alguien ya hemos visto las consecuencias
de las incitaciones del expresidente
el fiscal Federal devenido en abogado de
Trump Evan corcoren compareció este
viernes ante un gran Jurado Que
Investiga otro de los casos que
involucran al político republicano se
trata de la retención de documentos
clasificados después de dejar la Casa
Blanca además de acuerdo con la cadena
ABC un juez llamará a declarar al ex
jefe de gabinete de Trump Marc middles y
otros antiguos aliados por el tercer
caso que tiene abierto el asalto al
Capitolio muchos frentes de batalla para
quien planea luchar por el premio mayor
el retorno a la Casa Blanca
inició en República Dominicana La Cumbre
iberoamericana que reúne a presidentes
jefes de estado y representantes
gubernamentales de las naciones de
América Latina España Portugal Y andorra
en donde son abordados temas bilaterales
sobre medio ambiente y comerciales
previamente desde Santo Domingo Rosa
Pérez Mateo enviado especial de France
24 nos habló de los pronunciamientos más
relevantes de la jornada ha quedado muy
bien resumido lo que ha sucedido a lo
largo de la jornada con el discurso que
ha hecho el propio secretario
iberoamericano en esta misma ceremonia
en que ha hecho referencia a los tres
grandes documentos que se aprobarán
mañana y que hoy han quedado
prácticamente listos en la reunión de
cancilleres que se ha celebrado hoy que
es la carta medioambiental
iberoamericana la carta por los derechos
también digitales y el plan de ruta para
atajar la inseguridad alimentaria pero
como ya avanzamos aquí en France 24 al
tener acceso a un borrador que habían
preparado las distintas delegaciones se
ha caído la propuesta de un plan para la
nueva arquitectura financiera para que
la región pudiera acceder a mejores
condiciones en los créditos y en los
préstamos internacionales y solamente
para terminar el mismo secretario
iberoamericano ha hecho referencia a la
importancia de que España vaya a
presidir el consejo temporal de la Unión
Europea para acercar las relaciones
entre ambas regiones eso así ha sido un
comentario en ausencia de Pedro Sánchez
que todavía está viajando desde Bruselas
desde donde ha salido tarde en presencia
de España estaba Eso sí el rey Felipe vi
un juez de la Corte Suprema de México
ordenó suspender la implementación del
llamado Plan B la controversial reforma
electoral impulsada por el gobierno de
Andrés Manuel López Obrador Javier
lainez juez del máximo tribunal admitió
la controversia constitucional
presentada por el Instituto Nacional
electoral porque el polémico Plan B No
solo contiene normas de carácter general
sino también actos concretos de
aplicación
unas 90.000 personas marcharon en
Argentina para conmemorar el día de la
memoria verdad y Justicia cuando se
cumplieron 47 años del golpe de estado
que dio origen a la última dictadura del
país los manifestantes segregaron en la
Plaza de Mayo con pancartas y fotos de
los miles de desaparecidos para exigir
justicia por las víctimas se estima que
unas 30.000 personas fueron
desaparecidas durante la dictadura del
76 al 83
José Acosta Mi hermano en tucumán había
salido a trabajar no cañaverales y en
ese momento no vino fue un día 24 de
marzo que él estuvo marzo del 74 y para
nosotros hoy estar acá reflejando estos
40 años de democracia y este 24
es algo que nos lleva a continuar y
decir nunca más a lo que pasó porque
nosotros como familia la hemos pasado
cerramos también en Argentina donde hace
pocas semanas la ciudad de Rosario fue
noticia por un tiroteo contra uno de los
supermercados de la familia de Antonela
roccuzzo la influencer y modelo esposa
de Lionel Messi pero más allá de lo
sucedido la urbe vive un aumento de la
violencia relacionado con la presencia
de grupos narcotraficantes en la zona
en el barrio los pumitas se respira con
temor
calle solitarias fachadas con impactos
de bala son secuelas de lo que ha
conllevado el enfrentamiento entre
pandillas narcotraficantes fue aquí en
el norte de la ciudad argentina de
Rosario donde Maximiliano un niño de 11
años Fue asesinado por una bala perdida
durante un tiroteo entre dos bandas del
lugar
seguro pero nunca se ha metió con un
niño su residentes han presenciado el
aumento del tráfico de estupefacientes
en pequeñas escala así como el de la
violencia ante la falta de presencia
Estatal los vecinos han decidido tomar
sus propias medidas demoliendo la casa
de un presunto traficante unas acciones
por las que recibieron amenazas
consistían en llamadas telefónicas y
también
personales personalmente de que el club
iba a estar sembrado de muerto y bueno
pero también Nosotros tomamos la
decisión de seguir
porque nosotros estamos convencidos que
hasta la otra parte sabe que lo que
nosotros hacemos Es correcto la
desolación de los pumitas contrasta con
otros sectores de la ciudad con un
enorme Puerto Rosario es la puerta de la
agroexportación vital para el país pero
también se ha vuelto un punto de salida
de drogas hacia Europa y Asia el mercado
de mercancías ilegales que manejan
narcotráfico
ha permitido digamos un desarrollo
exponencial del mercado inmobiliario
también por ejemplo de los bienes
sutuarios o suntuosos que se venden aquí
como autos de alta gama el narcotráfico
y sus consecuencias Siguen sin poder ser
contrarrestados por el gobierno
Rosario es la ciudad más peligrosa de
Argentina con 22 asesinatos por cada
100.000 habitantes y con casi un
homicidio por día
fin del informativo gracias por su
sintonía
[Música]